kleinkriminalität das verbinden viele
mit bushido berlin neukölln und der
serie von blogs doch in der realität ist
die kleinkriminalität nicht etwas
romantisches sondern einfach nur
grauenvoll gestern versammelten sich in
duisburg bis zu 100 männer in zwei
gruppen es fielen schüsse menschen
wurden teilweise schwer verletzt und ein
großeinsatz folgte beteiligt sowohl
einen klaren mit ableger in berlin
gewesen sein unser thema heute abend
kleinkriege in deutschland verlieren wir
die kontrolle oder bevor im polizei und
medien sagen kleinkriminellen
rassistische vorurteile meine gäste
heute abend der bundesvorsitzende der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft rainer
wendt er plädiert für maximale härte im
umgang mit kleinkriminalität und findet
die clans sollen den staat fürchten der
gründer der arche bernd siggelkow der
seit jahren gegen kinderarmut und
vernachlässigung kämpft wenn es nach ihm
geht sollen die politiker mehr geld in
das bildungssystem und nicht immer in
die familienpolitik stecken journalist
georg iv der einst selbst als flüchtling
in die bundesrepublik deutschland kam
und zwei jahre lang in einem
arbeiterwohnheim in berlin-neukölln
gelebt hat er war der einzige deutsche
unter den ausländern sein spitzname war
professor ein mann schön dass sie da
sind antonia jamin ist deutsch
israelischen journalisten und
chefreporterin leitbild sie wird uns
berichten ob es in deutschland no go
areas gibt und damit herzlich willkommen
meine damen und herren zu einer
spezialausgabe von 14 8 fangen wir an
mit den jüngsten ereignissen nrw band
war das jetzt ein einzelfall oder nur
die spitze des eisbergs das wäre ja
schön wenn das ein zufall während wir
haben es ja fast schon daran gewöhnt in
berlin am hellichten tag werden leute
erschossen erstochen in duisburg ist es
auch kein einzelfall tut mir besonders
für meine heimatstadt dass es dort so
zugeht aber es ist längst schon traurige
realität nicht nur in großstädten
geworden dass clan sich auf offener
straße so ausdrücken und nicht nur das
auch dass sie ganz öffentlich und
ziemlich ungeniert ihre macht
demonstrieren diese mittel haben egal
frau hat man das kommen sehen diese
spaltung und diese kleinen kriminalität
also dass sie wirklich nur noch
kleinkriminelle dies war ich zu
bezweifeln in der klassifizierung da
haben wir doch fest gefügten strukturen
mittlerweile die auch uns großen
gewerblichen sinne kriminalität
betreiben nur ich möchte ihnen gleich zu
beginn etwas unorthodox es sagen ich
mich regt das nicht besonders auf ich
weiß nicht was die deutschen haben alle
großen städte in allen westlichen
demokratien haben solche zentren in new
york wird am tag drei viermal geschossen
das ist überhaupt abend in den news
überhaupt gar kein thema in london gibt
es street games das gibt es in los
angeles viertel die sind der südosten
von los angeles da können sie gar nicht
mehr hin als normaler mensch ja ich
werde aber der großstadt sein wir wollen
eine offene gesellschaft sein und da
können wir nicht zahlen spielen will ich
meine das thema denn also hat die
klangqualität in den letzten jahren
zugenommen obwohl natürlich aber ist
doch nichts besonderes ich kann damit
kein grund zur aufregung sind als auch
gehört zu einer freien gesellschaft
bitte die sagen einfach ok damit sein
dass ich sagen dass eine gesellschaft
vielfältig ist und dass auch das
dazugehört einer freien gesellschaft ist
die kriminalität eine erscheinung mit
der man leben muss in gesellschaften in
denen es keine kriminalität gibt sitzen
die kriminellen in der regierung wie in
moskau und da gibt es kontrollierte
kriminalität durch die regierung wenn
sie eine gesellschaft ohne kriminalität
wollen müssen sie diktatur haben die
seine offene gesellschaft wir können
geschäfte treiben und darf auch der böse
seine chance aber hier gibt es ja auch
hintergrund also dass diese leute ist ja
nicht
also die haben einen hinter prozent
glauben ganz deutlich und das gute ich
nicht wenn außerdem ist das völlig
falsch was sie sagen auch freiheitliche
gesellschaften offener gesellschaften
haben einen starken staat verdiente die
schwachen in dieser gesellschaft schützt
denn kriminalität die diebe stellten
sich ja nicht untereinander sondern es
gibt immer auch opfer wenn jetzt
erzählen sie einfach nicht ins
märchenstunden entschuldigung wir haben
an der polizei ist den sieben staaten
schritt in richtung ja ja der staat hat
die gesetzliche verpflichtung und auch
startpunkt weg ich habe in neukölln lebt
kommt ist kein polizist zu sehen weil
sie angst haben vor den mund nahm und
folk ist ja sie erzählen machen sie
keine pasta und wo in berlin sind 1000
mal 1000 polizei würde sie wirklich
bitten die impfung zu sagen ja auch
nicht beleidigen sie haben ist hier
wenig kulturarbeit es ist deutsche und
seht ihr andere hören
stimmt
sagt herr lernen
indem sie es nicht mehr hintrauen das
stimmt nicht es gibt es sowieso nicht
sagen deutschland es gibt eher sagen sie
herzlich ein zu spazieren
berlin
oder nicht also ich finde es erst mal
gewagt zu sagen wir müssen uns damit
abfinden dass es in einer gesellschaft
oder in einer großstadt in einer
metropole
gang kriminalität gibt ich bin selber
aus der polizei als kind aufgewachsen da
war gab es auch längst da hat man sich
nicht dran gewöhnt und natürlich gibt es
no go areas es gibt gegner tatsächlich
wo die polizei nicht so präsent ist wie
sie eigentlich sein sollte was ist gar
nicht schafft weil gar nicht genug geld
dafür ist bei der stadt einfach nicht
genug geld in die hand nicht mehr sie
haben auf der anderen seite auch blick
jetzt rede ich aber
auf der anderen seite gibt es natürlich
auch gründe warum menschen in gangs
landen oder auf der straße bleibt und
auf der strecke bleiben weil eben nicht
die noch gefahndet weil nicht genug
hingeschaut wird ich selber der auf der
straße auch groß geworden ist würde mit
diesem argument was sie sagen nicht
klarkommen weil ich habe auch auf die
schnauze gaben ich habe auch auf die
stolze gekriegt aber ist das die antwort
nein ist nicht die antwort wir müssen
etwas tun wir müssen als gesellschaft
auch als menschen auf see und ich wir
müssen vorbilder sein damit menschen
anders zugehen als wir als als was sie
gerade sagen und ich glaube wenn wir
besonders die polarisierung leben und
sagen wir sind jetzt berlin wir müssen
so sein wie new york oder los angeles
wer sind wir denn entweder haben wir
klare regeln wir haben klare vorbilder
wir haben klare grenzen oder nicht und
ich will keinen polizeistaat gar keine
frage aber wir brauchen regeln und
menschen brauchen regeln und sagt man ja
den lösungsansätzen und den regeln kann
mir gleich nach ich möchte einmal
antonia fragen gibt es denn für dich no
go areas hast du schon etwas erlebt
selbst ja also ich muss das mal klar
sagen ich als juden und ich als jüdische
frau es gibt stadtteile in berlin
neukölln zum beispiel dass ich selber
ganz alleine oder sogar mit freunde
nicht betreten wäre es werde entweder
jetzt vor ort wegen berichterstattung
und tatsächlich in den zwei jahren in
denen ich ohne vor ort war in köln wegen
berichterstattung ich habe in miami in
mein mikrofon auch geredet würde ich
zweimal angegriffen mit einem ball
einmal gab es genug polizei aber die
haben den vorfall überhaupt nicht
gesehen die polizei hat im nachhinein
auch ermittelt aber in den zwei mal hat
man die täter niemals gekriegt ob wenn
du hast du gar die täter fotografiert
hat er sagt ja also die im ersten mal
war waren die täter sehr klar im bild zu
sehen wochen danach habe ich einfach
eine meldung bekommen
wir schließen wir schließen das und ja
und ich habe jetzt auch vor kurzem eine
tochter bekommen und ich kann dir klar
sagen dass ich mich meine tochter jetzt
auch meine jüdische tochter jetzt nicht
in neukölln einfach so spazieren gehen
werde er der frau da ist auch die spanne
frage sollten wir das auch einfach
akzeptieren also kriminalität wir
sollten das nicht akzeptieren ich war
nur für die illusion das sollte ich
sagen dass in einer stadt von der größe
berlins von dem wirtschafts umschlag von
den geldmengen die hier unterwegs sind
das in einer freien gesellschaft und
nicht einer friedhofs gesellschaft dass
es dort wirklich es wirklich dazu kommen
kann kriminalitäts frei zu leben im
übrigen gibt es ganz andere form von
white collar kriminalität dies ist in
den feinen restaurants zu machen eine
rechnung für 1000 euro am abend umdrehen
ganz andere dinge verstehen sie also ich
bin dagegen dass wir diese art
plakativer demokratie hochspielen